Barbarian is full of some truly
eye-popping scares literally
what makes Barbarian such a roller
coaster of Terror is how it keeps its
answers in the dark to let your mind
simmer on the worst possibilities the
moment Tess played by Georgina Campbell
arrives at the double booked rental her
first discovery is learning somebody
else is staying in the house Keith
played by Bill Skarsgard she keeps her
guard up but eventually softens to the
idea one night Keith goes missing and
Tess hears his faint screaming coming
from downstairs Tess enters the dark
basement and manages to find a secret
doorway by pulling on a Roper coming out
of the wall the doorway opens up to a
pitch black space and makes your mind
rattle with possibilities
nope Tess works up the courage to enter
and as she travels into the dark space
that's when the stakes of the movie Rise
exponentially Tess discovers a dingy and
desolate Hidden Side room for the first
time which truly makes for a horrifying
moment the disgusting mattress sleazy
lighting and video camera make it feel
like Tess is walking into the setting of
a snuff film which sadly isn't far from
the truth the twists and turns mount on
top of each other as the film plays on
your assumptions AJ played by Justin
Long finds Frank's bedroom where he
discovers the snuff films Frank played
by Richard brake recorded as he
kidnapped women throughout his life the
room test found earlier in the film
serves as both an immediate scare and a
super terrifying the breadcrumb leading
us to Frank's backstory it's a story
that began decades ago the final
Discovery test makes is that the mother
everyone has feared all this time is
also a victim of her father's abuse
the mother is a constantly terrifying
thread throughout Barbarian but as her
initial debut that's the most terrifying
since it comes out of nowhere by the
time the mother enters the picture
you're completely engaged with Tess and
Keith's fun chemistry and their growing
Bond as well as the Intriguing mystery
that's afoot when she finally does
arrive towards the end of the First Act
you're totally in the dark about what's
really going on and it makes her
shambling out of the Shadows absolutely
horrifying just as tessen key three
unite in a dark and dingy tunnel the
mother comes from the Shadows to deliver
a terrifying fright and perform a
shocking and bloody kill on Keith by
repeatedly bashing his head against the
wall it's a moment where the horrors of
Barbarian really come out to play and
this an incredibly memorable way to hook
horror fans through a fantastic reveal
of a terrifying horror antagonist
AJ is such a clueless person that when
he first enters a house he mostly
ignores all the warning signs that
things are off he's so hopeless he
didn't that even when he finds the
secret room in the basement he thinks
nothing of it and whips out the tape
measure to see if he can get more value
out of the property AJ and knowingly
brings himself deeper into trouble as he
travels farther into the tunnels
eventually the mother starts to toy with
AJ by messing with his tape measurer
even ripping it away from him it's a
great moment of Comedy turning to horror
as it kicks off a wild Chase sequence
through the tunnels that leaves AJ
trapped and reveals Tess is still alive
plus the tape measure comes back later
in the film to nearly thwarts us escape
and provide a good jump scare in an
already tense moment
after AJ and Tess meets while being
captured by the mother you can't help
but wonder what she plans to do with
these two and the answer is truly
creepier than one's wildest imagination
viewers quickly learn why the creature
is credited as the mother as she tries
to perform motherly behavior on Tess and
AJ to make them like her children
however given the mother's grotesque
look motherly duties have never looked
so morbid
the entire sequence is a total nail
biter as Tessa's survival instincts
force her to blend into the situation by
reluctantly drinking the baby bottle
filled with the mother's breast milk
it's a nasty moments that hit you right
in the gut but it's ultimately a smart
choice given what happens to AJ when he
refuses it's tough not to be squirming
in your seats when the mother drags AJ
through the tunnels and breastfeeds him
overall barbarians certainly makes you
understand why the mother earns her name
and it couldn't be more disturbing
strange and heartbreaking
after both AJ and an injured test leave
the house they are sheltered by Andre
played by James Butler a local homeless
man who allows them a moment of Solace
as a mother continues to look for them
it's here that Andre discloses the
mother's gut-wrenching Origins and tries
to give AJ and Tess a moment to catch
their breath but good moments don't last
for long in Barbarian and with one
little comment about his place being
safe they end up being Andre's Famous
Last Words the sudden reappearance of
the mother results in a great jump scare
and not only kicks off a thrilling final
Chase but delivers a truly brutal kill
as the mother rips Andre's arm off and
beats him to death Barbarian features
some surprisingly gruesome kills
throughout and Andres is no different
it's a bloody end to a character with
good intentions and a memorably
terrifying moments that breaks the
calming atmosphere with sudden Terror
one of the earliest scares in Barbarian
comes when Tess and Keith are first in
the house together for the night and
Keith has a night terror that makes for
an unnerving sequence after Tess wakes
up from someone or something opening her
door and making a creepy sound while she
is sleeping she finds that Keith is
wrestling and moaning on the couch while
follows is an absolutely nerve-wracking
sequence showing Tess walking towards
Keith as he has some serious night
terrors Tess approaching Keith is purely
thrilling and the growing sounds of
Keats cries of Terror increased
attention immensely the jump scare that
comes from Keith suddenly waking up
delivers a perfect jolt to viewers and
acts as a great end Stinger to a scary
sequence it all ends with some good
laughs for the awkward exchange between
Tess and Keith but it's an unforgettably
tense moment early in the film that sets
the tone perfectly and instills some
good chills
even though we know that AJ is basically
the worst person ever as it becomes
clear that he's guilty of sexual assault
Tess doesn't know that and does
everything in her power to try and save
him after Tess initially escapes she
goes back into the house to Traverse the
dark corridors and eventually makes her
way back to the mother's room soon after
she notices a light peeking out through
the darkness and with one little
response she finds herself on the ground
with a bullet in her gut what Tess
didn't realize is that AJ was able to
get a pistol from Frank and is now
nervously going through the tunnel still
believing that the mother is hiding
somewhere thus when he sees a shadowy
figure standing just a short distance
away he doesn't hesitate to fire only
after he fires does he learn it was test
standing there the entire sequence is
thrilling the build-up to test returning
into the house is incredibly tense and
the moment she sees the light of AJ's
phone leaves you silent and then
instantly frightened by the well-timed
jump scare of The Gunshot you're left
even more scared afterward as Tess
clings on as she bleeds for the rest of
the film
just as all hope seems lost for tests
after the cops don't believe her and
she's once again left on her own she
decides to take the mother head-on with
the help of something mentioned by Andre
amongst his ramblings Andre mentions
that the mother only comes out at night
and with that knowledge Tess manages to
Ram her car into the mother when she
appears pinning her against the house
and then the process breaking the
windshield the anticipation leading up
to the moments the mother rises from the
small basement window is killer and when
she does appear it's through a sudden
scare it's incredibly creepy to watch
her slowly crawl out of the tiny window
hole and there is something satisfying
about SAS finally taking action against
the mother to try and go save AJ not to
mention it's super scary to see the
mother snarl and scream at Tess after
she gets hit by the car but it doesn't
keep her down for long
the entire last Act of Barbarian is full
of terrifying moments as AJ and Tess are
in a fight for their lives against the
mother while AJ might have a moment of
realization about his behavior that
doesn't mean he's a completely different
person who has magically turned into an
unselfish hero actually he's the
opposite of a hero as they approach the
finale by this point AJ has accidentally
shot Tess and he tries to sacrifice her
in the final moments of the chase just
to save her skin this forces her mother
to jump down and save Tess it's a moment
that's incredibly suspenseful since you
don't know if Tess or the mother
survived the fall at first it seems like
the mother isn't getting back up
unfortunately for AJ she does and she's
not letting him get away this time AJ's
death is one of the gnarliest kills of
the film as the murder not only pokes
out his eyes but crushes his head with
her bare hands director Zach kragger
doesn't hide anything either it's such
an incredibly gory and gross kill that's
satisfying because of how terrible AJ is
but it's also incredibly horrifying
because it's so graphic no one is
forgetting this kill that's for sure